let's go to kelly in whoo in guam
right down the street in guam kelly
what's going on
hi dr d thank you so much for taking my
call thanks for waiting so long while i
was
ranting about digital detoxes how are we
doing
i'm okay um you know i'm calling today
about my beautiful 17 and a half year
old baby girl
all right so her teenage years has been
a little rough
for the family but particularly on me in
the last three and a half years we've
dealt with two
pregnancy scares um and we've had to
work through those things as a family
with christian values
she she's not pregnant but after working
through these
events as a family and as a mother and
daughter i find that now moving forward
um i'm always suspicious of her now the
most recent scare was just this july
and i'm struggling with always
suspecting her of wrongdoing even when
she's innocent
and since this last pregnancy scare
she's actually done really well in
honoring our boundaries and our values
and i've explained to her that my trust
is very fragile
but i'm just always suspicious and i
don't want to spend the last
five months of her childhood life with
me suspicious of her and
i also don't want that to leak over into
my ten-year-old son who's
coming up into adolescence so hoping for
some advice
i love that thank you so much for the
for your trust here that's i appreciate
that man that's cool
um so there's several things here let's
let's back all the way up
so you've got you said you've got
christian values of your home
and so one of those values i'm going to
assume is
that you want to you don't want your
teenage daughter out having sex with
with other people right
correct okay so when you say there was
two pregnancy scare
events that sounds like a drum roll and
fireworks and lightning like
tell me what you mean when you say
events did you catch her with somebody
or did she come home and have a hard
conversation with you and say hey mom i
think i'm pregnant
did she have a pregnancy test that she
passed like tell me what the event was
okay so the first one was the more
chaotic one i actually didn't know what
had happened for over a year
when she was as young as just turning 15
she became very angry depressed dealt
with self-harm
it was just really difficult i didn't
know what was going on
i got her counseling and for a year i
just worked through this child who i
basically didn't know anymore
i had to do some work on my own self to
connect with her better
anyways after a year of this of
counseling of boundaries of working
together
with technology exactly what you've said
about technology i had to cut her off
her
technology for over a year
we found out she was inappropriately
interacting with this boy via technology
and so her dad got involved and
contacted his parents and cut we
basically cut them off
she was barely 15. so a year later after
all of this she finally told me
mom i slept with him and she was like i
got pregnant and i miscarried which i
cannot medically confirm because i don't
it was a year later
and i don't even know she know what that
meant right and so i mean it was
a huge upset it dramatically affected
our family but
like i said we did a lot of hard work
and so this last event in july it was
just one of those she came home i was
like
mom i'm late for my menstruation i took
a pregnancy test it was negative and i
was like
oh my god honey well those could be
inaccurate so we spent the weekend
i took her to the doctor and i spent the
weekend crying basically
waiting for those results those results
came back negative after that me and her
father sat her down and
we went over what our personal values
were where we stood
but the fact that she's almost an adult
and she's going to make these decisions
she's going to have to deal with them
and so that's basically how they
unfolded so the second event wasn't
i don't want to say it wasn't as
traumatic if you will
but still very it affected me greatly
so and so before i leave the first one
that's not a pregnancy scare okay
if a 15 year old got pregnant and
miscarried
that is a deep deep trauma yeah
okay so that's that's not a pregnancy
scare event
um i i don't know any
any adult in my life who hasn't had some
sort of pregnancy scare even if they're
married with a couple of kids
right yeah um that's that's that's that
goes with the territory
that's not what your daughter
experienced i have
um met with teenagers over the years who
become sexually active at a young age
and they go through a whole series of
depressive
episodes of like you mentioned cutting
self-harm stuff
because there's a disconnect between the
physical and the
the hormonal and then the emotional and
it just becomes a tidal wave for
for especially young teens and then you
throw into that
whether if she was truly pregnant and
truly miscarried
that's a loss of i don't know if you've
experienced that but that's a loss of
unimaginable depth that a 15 year old
just doesn't have the psychological
wiring to handle
i don't know i don't know any adult that
has the psychological wiring to handle
that on their own without a community
right
and so i want to characterize that the
right way
so then fast forward when she came to
you and said mom i'm
late and you spent the weekend crying
were you crying because your daughter
was
having sex again or were you crying
because you thought you're gonna be a
grandma
so i think my crying had more to deal
with like
blaming myself like how did i let this
happen to her again
how is this your fault well because i'm
her mom
and i mean i've spent so much time
trying to talk to her about the dangers
and
yeah but you
if a 17 year old wants to be a 17 year
old they're gonna be a 17 year old
and so right it's it's you're taking a
lot on if you if you
immediately run to the mirror and say
what have i done i gave her all the
information
and we know that like sexual activity
and teenagers is
is how they try to connect right that's
that's them trying to figure it out
and so yeah you can put up all kind of
fences and stuff teenagers
we've got 400 years we've got thousands
of years of literature about teenagers
figuring that out right how to get
around
walls and barriers and things yes sir um
so
and i'm telling you that not to minimize
what you went through but i'm just
trying to drill down
it sounds like you felt like you failed
yeah for
your teenage daughter violating your
boundaries true but
acting like a teenage daughter
and so i i want to get at um
were you disappointed in her were you
heartbroken or did you really just land
on
i suck as a mom because it happened
again
yeah that's that's where i landed okay
so your tears were more about
your perceived failures not about any
situation your daughter was in
well mina there was a little bit of oh
my gosh what about her future right you
know
there you go okay all right what does
that mean for her of course but
she's so she was very stoic about it she
was like
mom i'm gonna do what i have to do if i
am pregnant like and i'm of course like
maybe i'm here for you and she's like i
know mom but i'm gonna do what i gotta
do i made this choice
but i mean a lot of it because i guess
because of what i went through when she
was 14.
like it's just yeah and so here's the
thing
i i i missed an important thing and i'm
going to own that i missed it
your your daughter dealt with a
unimaginable trauma
but you did too and if you're still
characterizing the miscarriage of a
future grandkid
as a pregnancy scare that tells me you
haven't dealt with it either
and you might still be in the
performative aspect of parenting which
is um often for evangelical christian
kids
if i can keep them from having sex
drinking beer and
um smoking cigarettes and marijuana i
won
like and if they don't say bad words
that's even a bonus
on top right and we lump in those three
or four behaviors
and those are all well and good those
are all values behaviors those all have
negative outcomes attached to a lot of
them right
but often we sacrifice connection for
trying to like
truly connecting with my kid letting
them see what i'm
what i'm gonna model what these values
look like and it really diminishes
the connection because i'm just trying
to make sure that this behavior doesn't
happen
and i'm all about behavior prohibition
for teens
big time big time and i think we have um
completely swung that pendulum too far
the other way
asking 13 year olds how they feel about
things i don't care you're 13
right so i'm with you on those but
you've got to process the trauma too and
i bet your husband does as well
and if you haven't sat down and you said
i'm really proud of you said you did
your own work for a year
i hope that some of that was healing was
from that too
so you've reached an important point
that i hope every parent listening to
this hears i hope every wife
and every husband and every boss
everyone who's in a relationship with
other people
you have a suspicion now you created
a picture of a world that your daughter
was going to live into
and she didn't live into it and you
probably put some boundaries
on her like you can't you've got a
curfew you can't go out this time i
don't want you talking to that boy
and somehow she was a 17 year old and
she
found her way around the boundaries and
she slept with somebody again and now
you're suspicious of everything
and you also are wise enough to know
that that living that suspicious life if
you start
trying to always be thinking about
what's on her phone what's always in her
email accounts
where she might be where she's not be
i'm going to put my phone tracker app
that you realize that you were
distilling a relationship
down into a series of points and she's
going to go away in about half a year
she can be 18 she'll be gone
and you're going to realize i burned
that last half of that thing
fretting away those moments of
connection right
that's a really astute observation for
you as a mom i hope everyone's listening
to this
that we when we turn people into our
worst fears
we are choosing to disconnect from them
so here's a couple of things i would
tell you and these are just off the top
of my head
number one you are allowed to have your
suspicions
they're real and my guess is you had
some behaviors
um expectations of your daughter which
is right and good and i'm glad you did
and she violated them
again and so you're allowed to be
suspicious right that's a normal thing
i got a 10 year old and i'm suspicious
of him i got a five-year-old and i'm
super suspicious of her
right that's normal and good also
your kid's 17 you're allowed to say let
me see your phone
you're allowed to say where are you
going call me when you get there
i don't consider that and this is i'm
going to get mean cards and letters
i don't consider that a quote-unquote
invasion of their privacy they are
children they're children they have a
door on their room because we are
nice not because they quote unquote
deserve it okay so you're allowed to be
suspicious
at the same time you are real close to
having an adult
in your home and teaching them that
autonomy and teaching them how to
lean out of that is important so here's
the what i think is the greatest gift
you could give your kid
so this is number two number one is your
suspicions are good
they're fine good for you number two is
finding a way to both be honest with
your 17 and a half year old and
wise and what i mean by that say
when you feel suspicious sit down with
your daughter and say
i'm feeling suspicious something's not
right in my gut and i have
been wrong wrong over the course of your
life
do i have anything to be suspicious
about and
let her speak into it okay and what
what what you're doing is you're you're
showing your daughter vulnerability
you're showing her leadership you're
showing her accountability
and you are saying i'm gonna default to
trust even though you violated a few big
times because it sounds like
all the other times she's she's a pretty
good kid right oh yeah
um and like you said you started the
whole call with she's beautiful
and wonderful and she's had
sex and so i don't want all those things
to be divorced
from one another right they can all be
live in that same tension
but by showing her that you love her
enough to hold her accountable
and you love her enough to be vulnerable
and open with her you're going to
model for her what being a parent looks
like
you're going to model for her what being
a christian mom looks like someone who
both loves and wants to trust and is
still struggling with
that that moment and then if you find
out that she's lying to you again you're
going to hold her accountable
if you find out she's violating your
core family values
you're going to hold her accountable and
i think
being honest with her about that tension
because here's what kids do
okay kids feel that tension on their
parents
and they backfill that tension with it's
my fault
i suck i can't make my
mom feel right about me and the way kids
interpret that is a violation of a
relationship and it's their fault
and then they set about all kinds of
different behaviors and ways of coping
with that disconnection
some kids try to be perfect some kids go
burn down the neighborhood
some kids try to get straight a's some
kids quit going to class
some kids smoke weed some kids go get
bunches of girlfriends some
fill in the blank but it's kids are
always trying to reach out and reconnect
and reform those relationships
especially when they feel that gap and
that tension with their parents
and so that tension is going to be there
when you feel that suspicion
like she's like i'll be back at 10 i'm
going to study spanish at susan's house
and your alarms go off when you're like
bull crap you're not right
like you're not and now you've got a
you've got a backlog you've got some
things where she's
gone to study so you think and you also
have some data that says sometimes she
doesn't go
study sometimes she goes and hooks up
with somebody
right then there's that tension and she
feels it you feel it you all feel it
and that's when you as the adult the
wise one get to lean into that and say
all right let's talk i my my suspicion
alarms just set off
it might be me but i was a 17 year old
girl once too
and it might not be so here's what i
think i think you're gonna go do x y and
z
and i feel like i want to look at your
phone when i say that what do you what
do you think
and let her speak into it and then you
get to own the conversation you get to
own the wisdom you get to own the
um vulnerability there and then you let
her get to practice being an adult is
she going to be honest with you
she's going to tell you the truth et
cetera et cetera how does that sound
when i say that
it sounds you know along the lines of
what i've been working towards
awesome because i mean yeah there was
one time like i caught her
she was up at like 4 00 a.m i was like
what are you doing awake and so we had
this argument and i was just honest i
said baby you have to understand
my trust is very fragile and we have to
work together to fix that
so one thing i would add number one good
for you for having a conversation
and for leaning into that number two
four a.m is never a good time to have
existential conversations about trust
right
because then she gets she's exhausted
and
that that her ability to think clearly
and respond
appropriately and respectfully is thin
and then ability to respond
respectfully and authentically and wise
is thin
that's when you circle back that next
weekend or that next night or that
evening and say dude look
4 30 no no way dude no teenager on
in guam is just hanging out at 4 a.m
because they're doing math homework
right they're not right
um and so i i i think you're right on
the right track
i do feel your feelings and just
ask them for data for truth
and if you feel suspicious trust your
gut you've been right a lot
and lean into wisdom and trust with your
daughter
i think you're that's a good place and i
want to
honor the fact that you and your husband
set boundaries and values for her
and most of the time she follows him and
a couple times she hasn't
and you still are defaulting to the fact
that you love her you think she's
wonderful
i think giving her good education and
not just scare tactics but good
education and also
being vulnerable you can't about your
own story if you have your own stories
letting her get to see what's in the
heart and mind
of a good mom and a good wife
and a good person just trying to make
through the day
but man it sounds like y'all are right
on the right track
and the more vulnerable you can lean
into that while still holding
firm to your values and affirmed that
accountability kelly you're
you're teaching a young kid
how to become a young woman how to
become a young adult
and good for you that young girl's lucky
to have you
wouldn't do 4 a.m conversations but
she's lucky to have you that's super
super good